hi it's me jackson
today i'm gonna make
something very special for you we're
gonna make my favorite pizza i'm making
this one for my dad for father's day
me and my dad eat pizza a lot
i think he would really like this
if i make it for him i love my dad so
much
what makes your dad cool
when he loves his hat
[Music]
oh man
this is the cheesiest pizza you'll ever
eat
it has cheese in the crust and it has
cheese on top
you have to tuck the dough
over the trees really well
or oust the cheese or leak out
when i grow up i hope i can be with my
dad
what about me
i'm gonna be like
my dad and my momma
is there anything you want to say to
your dad i love you and thank you for
everything you do i love pepperoni on my
pizza but you can put yourself what you
want on yours all right guys that's it i
hope you have a nice father's day i'm
gonna enjoy this pizza with my dad i
hope you make it for your dad he will
love it i like pizza i like pizza i like
pizza pizza pizza pizza oh yes
[Music]
you